[Applaus]
der fc liverpool hat am sonntag die
champions league meisterschaft gefeiert
trainer jürgen klopp vom mit der
mannschaft im offenen doppelstockbus
durch die stadt tausende menschen
säumten die straßen und jubelten ihren
helden zu
[Applaus]
es hat mir sehr gut gefallen jede
sekunde war toll
es war großartig denn hier sind viele
leute die ich kenne
wir singen und die ganze erfahrung war
einfach einmalig euphorisierend
euphorisierend einfach schön ich meine
es gibt keine bessere stadt auf der welt
oder die gemeinschaft das gefühl alle
sind einfach unglaublich unglaublich
liverpool hatte beim champions league
finale am samstag in madrid tottenham
hotspur mit 2 0 geschlagen
den auftakt machten aus salat er einen
strafstoß verwandelte in der zweiten
halbzeit baute die woche regie dann die
führung aus
[Applaus]
ja